hey this is truly truly deplorable and
also insanely scary Donald Trump's staff
tricked him into going along with that
botched Yemen raid reportedly by sort of
goading him by saying hey you know what
Obama would not have been bold enough to
do this I told you earlier this week
about that botched military raid in
Yemen it led to the deaths of 30
civilians it led to the death of US navy
to a of a US Navy SEAL it failed to kill
its target the al-qaida leader Kasim Al
rimi which Donald Trump reportedly
casually authorized this raid during
dinner Defense Secretary General James
mad dog mattis and the chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff General Joseph
Dunford reportedly convinced Trump to go
ahead with the raid by suggesting to him
you know Obama would never have been
bold enough to actually go through with
this thing Trump heard that and
apparently said where do I sign my name
to this thing the president is being
played like a chump
not only by Russian intelligence and
Vladimir Putin but now by members of his
own staff his own cabinet oh stop
overreacting David I mean we have checks
and balances in our system and there's
nothing like this could ever happen well
welcome to the Trump era but there's
another angle to this because if this is
true I wonder if Steve Bannon was
setting up madis to be the scapegoat for
a failed operation at some later point
in time right you're Bannon if we
believe Bannon is sort of really the guy
in charge here if we believe Bannon is
to trump as Cheney was to Bush but even
to a greater extent and you want to see
this raid happen
you convinced mattis to go when you say
here's what you tell him okay you go in
there and when the shrimp cocktail comes
out he's gonna be really distracted cuz
he loves that shrimp cocktail you tell
him you know mr. President Obama would
never have had the testicular fortitude
to do this you should do it and then if
it fails you just go back and say whoa
mattis came in and he convinced Trump
this is all on mattis he has his bases
covered there I think I mean there's a
clear reason why Obama wouldn't
authorize this raid because there wasn't
enough intelligence on the ground and
you thought that the risk to reward
ratio just wasn't there so he probably
just should have done the same thing
when in doubt no absolutely and I'm
reminded when I imagine the scenario
Rachel I imagine now come on you know
who didn't eat their vegetables like a
big boy Barack Obama
that's who you eat your vegetables Donny
that's effectively the strategy that's
being reported here that convinced from
to authorize a raid that led to the
deaths of 31 people but this was not
this has been on a larger scale - this
is why certain Republicans voted for him
because they wanted to get their Supreme
Court pick which they did so if
everyone's using this strategy where are
we going to be left in a few years not
in a good place and the other thing I
thought of Pat was that the facts are
also wrong who believes that President
Obama wouldn't have gone along with this
type of raid if it actually makes sense
as Pat mentioned Obama didn't authorize
this particular raid because he didn't
believe that the risk reward ratio made
sense for an authorization but President
Obama authorized a very risky raid after
a lot of consideration and it was the
raid that led to the killing of Osama
bin Laden one that carried big risk and
succeeded so even the trick that's being
used on Trump is based on the faulty
logic that Obama wouldn't have
authorized such a raid
and while the Osama bin Laden raid was
going on Barack Obama was sitting in the
Situation Room with all of his advisors
around him reportedly Trump was just
that dinner and wasn't willing to go
there what I read was that he was in the
residence during the time that this raid
was going on yeah I mean I I just AM so
curious like we know President Obama was
reading a lot right he would be up in
the residence he'd be reading everything
from autobiographies to nonfiction and
novels reading reading reading reports
and briefings etc do you imagine that
Trump just sits up there watching TV and
I don't know playing snood on his phone
or something like I really don't know
what it is he's doing up there i I don't
I also just don't believe that he has
kind of a basic historical knowledge
that many other presidents have come in
equipped with and that is going to yeah
completely shocking and that is not
going to fare well for him I wonder how
many presidents Donnell
Trump can name certainly not all 4445
maybe two two I'm if I had to put the
over-under on how many so I think he
could definitely get Washington and
Lincoln himself he would get both bushes
and himself that's five he probably
wouldn't name Obama no well he would
yeah that's clever
he would name Obama and Clinton so that
gets us to seven Teddy Roosevelt and FDR
III assume he would get in Nixon so that
gets us to ten here's the real question
would Trump name Ford is Trump aware of
Gerald Ford if you were to just say
willy nilly name the president's for me
I I mean I he was alive at that time so
I think he would know who that is yeah
but he wouldn't just come up with that
name I would put I think a fair
over-under for naming presidents for
Trump would be 13 okay I think that at
13 10 and 13 I would I would say that's
right yeah okay after the break I think
you're really going to like this I'm
going to speak to information warfare
expert Molly McHugh she wrote a
stunningly good article called Putin's
long game recently and we're going to
talk to her after the break Gamefly is
sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s